skillful pilots gain their reputation
from storms and tempest
why should i fear death if i am death is
not if death is i am not why should i
fear that which can only exist when i do
not
the greater the difficulty the more the
glory in surmounting it
being happy is knowing how to be content
with little
he who has peace of mind disturbs
neither himself nor another
[Music]
live your life without attracting
attention
the things you really need are few and
easy to come by but the things you can
imagine you need are infinite and you
will never be satisfied
we should look for someone to eat and
drink with before looking for something
to eat and drink
he who is not satisfied with a little is
satisfied with nothing
it is folly for a man to pray to the
gods for that which he has the power to
obtain by himself
all friendship is desirable in itself
though it starts from the need of help
death does not concern us because as
long as we exist death is not here
and when it does come we no longer exist
the noble soul occupies itself with
wisdom and friendship
do not spoil what you have by desiring
what you have not
remember that what you now have was once
among the things you only hoped for
what will happen to me if that which
this desire seeks is achieved and what
if it is not
god is all-powerful god is perfectly
good evil exists if god exists there
would be no evil therefore god does not
exist
of all the things which wisdom provides
to make us entirely happy much the
greatest is the possession of friendship
you don't develop courage by being happy
in your relationships every day
you develop it by surviving difficult
times and challenging adversity
the art of living well in the art of
dying well or one
happiness is man's greatest aim in life
tranquility and rationality are the
cornerstones of happiness
if god listened to the prayers of men
all men would quickly have perished for
they are forever praying for evil
against one another
i never desired to please the rabble
what pleased them i did not learn and
what i knew was far removed from their
understanding
pleasure is the first good it is the
beginning of every choice and every
aversion it is the absence of pain in
the body and of troubles in the soul
riches do not exhilarate us so much with
their possession as they torment us with
their loss
in a philosophical dispute he gains most
who is defeated since he learns most
not what we have but what we enjoy
constitutes our abundance